Welcome to AERA English's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d' Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
Okay, today's Maestro Hook.
Now, Maestro Hook is a good conversation piece you can use with a foreigner when you're speaking.
Today's Hook is about getting picked up and meeting someone special.
A lot of foreigner girls I know say they've never been picked up in Japan.
You know, even if they're beautiful and they're sitting in a bar by themselves,...
...no one picks them up because Japanese guys are scared to talk to a foreigner girl...
...because they don't speak English.
Now, in a situation like that,...
...I have two perfect lines you can use to pick up a foreigner girl, okay?
You from around here?
Thought I saw an angel.
So, Maestro Lines.
Hey, you from around here?
I haven't seen you before.
Oh no, I just came to Tokyo.
Why don't I show you around?
Excuse me. Oh! I thought I saw an angel.
No, just kidding, but are you from around here?
So, if you wanna pick up girls, foreigners, and you wanna speak good English,...
...please use these lines and practice, okay?
Thanks a lot and I'll see you again...
...and, please watch again on Native Maestro. Bye-bye!